depuis hier partout en france des
producteurs de fruits et légumes partent
à la rencontre des consommateurs plutôt
récalcitrant par les prix une opération
de sensibilisation baptisée la
fraich'attitude reportage chilienne
sylvain éric jamais manger beaucoup de
fruits et légumes vous arranger combien
par jour
non
ok un seul
moi je dirais plus de 5 suis pas
tellement pourri mais plutôt aux gâteaux
pour être en bonne santé il faudrait
manger au moins cinq fruits et légumes
par jour mais ça n'est pas gagné pour
toulouse de la consommation les
producteurs de fruits et légumes face à
l'attack donc cet atelier culinaire
parisien il s'agit d'apprendre à les
cuisiner sans préjuger pas du luxe
je voudrais plus mal que c'est
essentiellement que les crudités
je sais que c'est plus simple pour moi
je voulais avoir d'autres idées pour les
cuisiner rapidement fait voilà au menu
du jour donc soupe de concombre aux
quatre épices et sa marmite de tomates
farandole provençal sur lies d'oignons
confits
ça s'appelle la fraich'attitude c'est du
marketing maison fait l'objectif est
simple les jeunes ados ne simplicité et
c'est une des barrières à la
consommation de fruits et surtout de
légumes sont souvent les gens ne
consomment pas parce qu'ils ne savent
pas comment coupant une tomate comme
oculaire haricots verts un petit peu de
parmesan et vous gratuits sur ce marché
parisien on ne demande pas mieux d'avoir
la fraîch'attitude
le problème pour ces consommateurs
serait le prix on est en pleine saison
il ya des problèmes
récolte ça on le sait mais ça reste trop
cher pour les budgets et la marchande
confirme un peu en vend des parts de
kilos maintenant c'est aux 500 drams a
dégénéré du zoo
dans les faits les prix des légumes ont
augmenté de 6% en un an mais les fruits
ont légèrement baissé
les consommateurs ont tendance à trouver
que les prix des fruits et légumes
augmentent plus vite qu'il n'augmente
réellement parce qu on leur préfère
autre chose en particulier les bardes
aliments tout préparés et cetera qui
quand on y réfléchit bien sont
finalement malgré tout assez cher et
bien souvent plus chers que les fruits
et légumes
ce jour là avec trois plats mais sans
compter le poisson le repas s'élevait à
moins d'un euro par personne